now if you follow this channel you know
that i am nothing if not
completely plugged in to pop culture uh
in fact that you know that's what the
kids
always say they're always saying gee
whiz that that matt walsh guy he knows a
lot about pop culture
i've heard him say it down at the
skateboard park
um so that's why today i'm going to
review
a new joint uh this is hot off the
presses it's a new song from a woman
named addison ray who's a tick-tock star
turned pop singer so she made the jump
from posting 15 second
mindless vapid content to posting
mindless vapid content that's two and a
half minutes long
so it's a it's a risky move it's a risky
play we'll see if it pays off or addison
ray's new single
that all the kids are talking about
again is called obsessed that's the name
of the song
she posted a couple days ago he's got
millions of views and uh it's making
waves
people are excited about it people are
obsessed you might say
let's uh let's give it a watch here it
is
[Music]
on the dashboard
okay now let's um we'll pause it there
for just a minute
we've got addison on a motorcycle there
first of all
now this in in spite of the fact that
nobody named addison
has ever actually ridden on a motorcycle
in real life that's
that's a scientific fact but what i
really want to focus on are the lyrics
she says
you turned our song down baby what for
you had lit candles on the dashboard red
roses growing out the door
want to say something you never said
before
so candles on the dashboard
lit candles on the
dashboard of your vehicle how is that
even
possible first of all and why who brings
candles into their car
i can't imagine what would happen if we
were driving along
and i pulled out some candles and said
to my wife hey baby let's uh
let's light these up and set the mood a
little bit she would probably call the
cops is what would happen so i do not
recommend this this is not good
this is not this is not fire safety this
is not driving safety i do so don't
don't don't take this song that way
i'm a little bit confused already but
let's uh let's keep watching
[Music]
and i said
[Music]
i can't lose when you say that you're
obsessed with me me too
okay so a few things to review here
where to begin
uh first thing that springs to mind for
me watching that
is the dancing it is is that i'm not an
expert
is that do we call it good dancing is
that what good dancing looks like
that dancing to me seems mildly terrible
and it makes you appreciate maybe other
pop stars who
can't really sing can't do anything but
they can at least dance so the first
when you see a pop star or wanna be pop
star who can't dance
you sort of you realize what you're
missing this is like the bridesmaid
three hours into the reception after
nine glasses of wine
that's that's like that level of dancing
is what you're getting who am i to judge
i don't know
i don't dance but if i did i would look
like a praying mantis having a seizure
so i guess i can't really judge too much
still you'd expect more from someone who
wants to make a pop song
was there no director for this video was
there nobody to stop the camera
and uh stop shooting and say okay hang
on addison you listen
um you you look stupid
let's try this again so they didn't have
anyone to do that
but second point is the lyrics okay
lyric she says we were driving down
sunset
you know i love fast cars passed by
where we first met
damn we made it so far red eyes from the
red light and that just set the mood
you say you're obsessed with me so i
took a second and said
me too i'm obsessed with me as much as
you
say you die for me i'd die for me too
and if i lost you
i'd still have me i can't lose would you
say that you're obsessed with me
me too now i just made that sound better
through my performance i think that it
really deserves
you're obsessed with yourself
that's the message of the song how is
that something
you want to announce to the world that
you're obsessed with yourself
you might as well make a song bragging
about your toe fungus this is like
this is a repulsive trait that you
should not be proud of
can you imagine someone saying this to
you
in person maybe like on a date or
something and someone actually said that
to you
but you ask them you know what they're
into what their hobbies are all those
dumb questions you have to ask on a
first date
and they say well you know i like hiking
i'm a big music fan
mainly i like myself uh i'm obsessed
with myself
i gotta tell you i am obsessed with
myself
that's called being a narcissist addison
that is not it's and it's not attractive
it doesn't make you an interesting
person it doesn't make you confident
it makes you seem totally pathetic and
sad i feel sorry for you especially with
the dancing
especially when you're dancing like a
damned tropical bird uh
on top of saying you're obsessed with
yourself it's pathetic there's nothing
attractive about this at all but let's
uh let's keep going so tight you can't
even speak
[Music]
music's so loud
[Music]
i can't lose when you say that you're
obsessed with me me too i'm obsessed
with me
ee as much as you say you die for me i
die for me
too and if i lost you i'd still have me
i can't lose when you say that you're
obsessed with me me too
i just want our civilization to die at
this point i think we deserve it
we really do oh man i can't get over the
dancing isn't the dancing bad tell me if
i'm wrong it just looks really bad to me
now let's go back to these lyrics again
such as they are um she said
i did my hair like waves on the beach
this dress so tight
you can't even speak my heels so high
might get a nosebleed
music's so loud but i hear your
heartbeat
we were driving down sunset you know i
love fast cars passed by when we first
met
damn you made it so far red eyes from
the red light
not just set the mood you say you're
obsessed with me
so i took a second and said
me too all right first of all there are
like
12 actual words in this song repeated
over and over again
but let's try to figure this out addison
is obsessed with herself
can't get enough of herself she loves
herself she's obsessed with herself
she's the greatest and why
like does she if you're going to put if
that's going to be
the hook if that's going to be the the
chorus like that's what you're saying
over and over again
you're obsessing yourself you're so
great well then i would think the verses
should be
you building a case like telling us
why you're so great justifying that
level of ego
and if you say in the in the verse of
the song um i cured cancer
you know i i figured out a way to break
uh to travel faster than the speed of
light like
if you put that in there then i'm gonna
say okay i'll give it to you i'll let
you be obsessed with yourself
but what does she tell she tells us that
um what makes her so great she
has wavy hair and a tight dress
and high heels that's it that's the only
thing we're told that's the only
information we're given
to justify her her um level of
self-confidence
okay so she's dressed like every other
22 year old girl at a bar
in other words and we're just gonna
we're gonna leave aside the laziest
metaphors i've ever heard in a song
she was trying to think of a simile for
wavy hair
you know this is the kind of song
writing we're getting and so she was
like
i want to say my hair is wavy so
i did my hair like what what i want to
say it's wavy what did it look like
oh i got it waves my hair was wavy like
waves
but the main point is that this shows i
think the utter emptiness
of the kind of self-love that's promoted
in pop song in pop culture generally
look you know there have always been you
could point out there have always been
shallow boring self-involved morons in
the world that's true
but the difference is that now we
actively encourage
people to be that way we literally
celebrate
that we celebrate the absolute worst
personality a person can have
we encourage it and celebrate it but the
thing is we've all known people like
this in real life right like
and there's nothing good to say about
them we've all encountered people like
addison and usually their name is
addison
and i'll tell you what's going to happen
next addison's this is my prediction
addison's next big single is going to be
a mournful
taylor swift x s ballad
about heartbreak you know lamenting how
she can't find a good man
complaining about the guy who dumped her
she's alone
that and but when that song comes out
remember this is the prequel this is the
prequel to that song
of course you're not gonna find a decent
person of course your relationships are
gonna fall apart
you're you're selfish and shallow and
proud of it
and selfish shallow people end up alone
deservedly so and then you get what you
want right
you get to be by yourself forever you're
obsessed with yourself
well congratulations because that's all
you're ever going to have
for the rest of your life until you die
alone and cold
and forgotten but other than all that
pretty good song